[संगीत]
सो हेलो गाइस कैसे हो आप सभी लोग मैं आ
गया फिर से एक और एसल का सेशन लेके माय
नेम र्म डेफ डेनिक्स तो सबसे पहले तो सबको
मैं कांग्रेचुलेशन कहना चाहूंगा अपना जो
चंद्रयान थ था वह सक्सेसफुली लैंड कर गया
है अपने मून
पर
सो सबको बहुत बहुत ज्यादा कांग्रेचुलेशन
एंड मैन गो टू लवेज हा
सो आज अपन अपनी क्लास डे फोर पर है ठीक है
सो पिछली जो क्लासेस थे उसका अपन रिवीजन
नहीं करने वाले जैसे मैंने लास्ट टाइम
बताया था क्योंकि अपन उन्ही चीज को य पर
फिर से रिपीट करेंगे ही एक बार क्योंकि
अपन को पुराना एक बार आप से करना ही पड़
जाता है एसल के अंदर या फिर आपकी जो
पुरानी वाली फाइल थी वो भी भी य पर सेव्ड
है उसी फाइल के अंदर अपन आगे काम करते
रहेंगे सो इस चक्कर के अंदर जिन लोगों के
लिए आज की क्लास फर्स्ट क्लास है
प्लीज पुरानी क्लासेस भी देखकर आना
क्योंकि क्या है कि मतलब फिर चीज थोड़ी
ऊपर से जंप हो जाती है आर लाइक की इट्स
एडवांस एडवांस नहीं है ब्रो बिल्कुल बेस
से चालू किया है इवन वी स्टार्टेड फम व्ट
इज डेटा तो डेटा बेस से पले ट डाटा ठीक है
हा तो अपन चालू करते हैं अपनी आगे की
क्लास
सो आज अपन पढ़ेंगे सेलेक्ट के बारे में
मैंने कल थोड़ा सा सेलेक्ट का एक चिंटू सा
पार्ट दिखाया था ठीक चिंटू ही कहेंगे
उसको पार्ट चिंटू ही था तो अप इसको थोड़ा
अच्छे से लत के देखने वाले हैं लत के ना
ठीक है तो मैं अभी जाता हूं अपना ये
अपना
था जो लास्ट टाइम यूज किया था अपने सारी
कमांड य लिखी हुई है एंड मैं अपना
एसक्यूएल खोल लेता हूं एसल खोलने के लिए
बताया था स्टार्ट प जाने का अपना ऑल एप्स
के अंदर जाने का ल एस में जाने के बाद में
यहां पर ओ के अंदर जाने
का ठीक है
डेटा बेस जीी एंड रन एल
कमांड ठीक
तो मैं इसको अच्छे से लगा देता हूं आप लोग
कोने अच्छा
लगे तो सबसे कनेक्ट करता टा बेस से
कनेट ठीक है
अपन कनेक्ट कर दिए हैं अपने डेटाबेस
से सो अभी अपने पास जो टेबल है व टेबल कौन
देखते चलो एक बात बताओ मेरे को अगर टेबल
का स्ट्रक्चर देखना हो तो मैं कौन सी
कमांड लिखू जिससे मुझे टेबल का स्ट्रक्चर
दिख
जाएगा टेबल का स्कीमा मैं कहना चा
स्कीमा कमेंट में बताओ कि मैं क्या लिखू
यहां पर मैं बस एंप्लॉई करके टेबल था
मैंने हा टेबल का नाम चेंज किया था
एंप्लॉई करके तो मैं क्या लिखू यहां पर
जिससे मैं एंप्लॉई टेबल का स्कीमा देख
सकू
डीएससी टेबल टेबल
नेम ठीक
है
डीएसी डीएससी टेबल नहीं लगाते हैं ठीक है
डी सीधा अपन टेबल का नेम ही लिखते हैं ठीक
है टेबल टेबल ऐसा नहीं होता हर जगह ऐसा
नहीं चलता है लॉजिक से अप्लाई किया लेकिन
ऐसा नहीं होता
है ठीक है तो अपने टेबल इसन एप्ल आईडी ले
रहे नेम ले रहे फोन नंबर ले रहे स्ट ले
रहे ले रहे ठीक है ठीक है बा तो अच्छी
है
हा तो अभी अपन क्या करने वाले हैं ना अभी
शायद इसम कोई डाटा पड़ा नहीं है
सेलेक्ट स्टार
फ्रॉम
एंप्लॉई देखते है इसमें अभी कोई डाटा नहीं
पड़ा तो अपन पहले इसमें डाटा डाल देते हैं
ता क्या होना कि अपने लिए इजी सा हो
जाए सेलेक्ट को ढंग से देखने के लिए
सेलेक्ट के अंदर बहुत सारी चीज देखने वाले
हैं अभी जो मैं आज बताने वाला हूं वो एकदम
वो भी छोटा सा पार्ट है इसके आगे और भी
ज्यादा चीज रहेंगी एंड आगे आते आते आप जो
लोग एल इंजेक्शन वगैरह करते थे एसक्यूएल
मैप का जिन लोगों ने इस्तेमाल किया था वो
लोग शायद ना अगर उन्होंने एसक्यूएल मैप के
अगर वर्वस मोड में देखा हो एसल मैप को तो
उसके अंदर जो लिखा हुआ आता था वैसा कुछ
सिमिलर आपको आगे देखने को मिल सकता है
अपने इसके अर ठीक
है पाइथन लिखा हु मैंने सीरीज के पाइथन भी
पढ़ाया था ठीक है ए पढ़ रहा तो होप आप लोग
खुद का बना सको
टूल थोड़ा हार्ड होगा लेकिन हो जाएगा ठीक
तोले डटा इंसर्ट करेंगे मैंने कमांड बता द
पूछने वाला सवाल ठीक है इंसर्ट
इनटू अपना टे का नाम क्या
है
वैल्यू अभी मैं से एक बार चालू कर लेता
हूं 10 और नेम के अंदर य पर जिन जिन के
इधर नेम है वही ने
ता
जैसे भाई का
है अगला है अपना फोन नंबर फोन नंबर कु भी
डाल देते
टूथ 4 5 6 7 8 ना
10 ठीक है और स्टेट के अंदर
अपन भाई कहां से हो यार आप गुजरात ल
गुजरात क्या डाला था मैंने आपके लिए
गुजरात आपने बताया था ठीक है गुजरात य पर
डाल देता
हूं हा और सैलरी आपकी क्या रखी है
मंथली के हिसाब से रखेंगे ली हिसाब से
नहीं रखेंगे तो 800 रख देता
हूं बुरा मत मानना मतलब तना बुरा भी नहीं
है ब ठीक
है ऐसे नॉर्मली मैंने रखा है और कुछ सीन
नहीं है और साथ के अंदर अभी यहां पर
रुद्रा रुद्रा है अपने पास य ल रुद्रा
रुद्र
आपके फोन नंबर थोड़ ब च करता क्यों कर रहा
हूं सेम क्यों नहीं रख रहा क्योंकि अपने
मैंने बताया था अपने रू ल लगे हुए हैं ठीक
है राजस्थान से मे
से
नगा आपके पास इंक्रीमेंट सरी में
ठीक
म मत केफ
भाई आप कहां से हो अगर आप अभी ऑनलाइन हो
तो
कम ऑन यार इंटरेक्ट बनाते हैं चीज को ममद
क्या आप रहते हो या से में अभी हो कि नहीं
आव नो
आईडिया दिल्ली ओके दिल्ली वाले हो
आप ठीक है तो आपको भी जारी कर देते है
हमारे
मीत और और कौन कन
है कृष्णा करके एक बंदा था अभी है कि नहीं
नो आईडिया इस मैं देख पहली
बार कृष्णा पुरोहित क्या नाम सुना सुना लग
रहा क
पु कोई
नहीं न
चें कृष्णा पुरोहित भाई कहां से हो आप
महाराष्ट्र
महाराष्ट्र इनकी सैलरी अभी अपन 6 करते
हैं बत मानना मैं ऐसे ही लिख रहा हू
नहीं चाहता आप की सरी ऐसी हो बट नहीं ब
एपल ग केब से एटलीस्ट पाच छ लिखूंगा तो
थोड़ा जही रहेगा इसके अंदर अपन को बहुत
सारी चीज देखनी है जो मतलब अपने लिए अच्छा
रहेगा इन चीजों को चेंज
करना राजस्थान तां
य
भावे
ठीक
है इनका
90 ठीक है तो मैंने पाच टा य पर रख लिए है
मैं इनको एक बार डाल के देखता इनको एक साथ
में य देखो एक और फायदा मिल जाता है पेस्ट
करूगा देखो एक साथ सारे के सारे बन जाते
हैं र मैं कमांड लिखले कैसे कर तो मैं बस
आपको दिखाना चाह रहा था एक करके मैंने
आपको किया चक्कर में ताक मैंको दिखा
सकू तो भी मैं य पर व अपना सेलेक्ट स्टार
फ्रॉम एप्ल लिख
के एंटर करता हूं तो य पर पूरा डटा आराम
से एकदम झकास तरीके से आ गया है अपने पास
में ठीक य सबका सल बुरा माना सरी कम लग
ठीक हा तो अभी अपन देखने वाले हैं के बारे
में ठीक है ना तो देखो अभी मैंने आपको चीज
बताई सेलेक्ट स्टार फ्रॉम य स्टारस भी
बोलते हैं कुछ जगह पर मतलब शद हर जग बोलते
है हा तो मैं स्टार ही बोलूंगा इसको तो
स्टार से क्या रहता है ना ये कहता है कि
सब कुछ जो भी है ना अपने पास जो भी कॉलम्स
है ना वो सारे के सारे कॉलम्स मुझे यहां
पर लाके दिखा दो कॉलम्स की र् सेलेक्ट
अपने वैल्यूज दिखाता है तो य जो स्टार रता
है यन कॉलम स्पेसिफाई करने देते है ठीक है
तो स्टार का मतलब होता है कि सारे के सारे
कॉलम एंड अगर य स्पेसिफिक कॉलम भी
स्पेसिफाई कर सकता हूं जैसे सेलेक्ट नेम
मतलब मुझे य पर ईम पी
आईडी और नेम चाहिए
फ्रॉम एप्ल ठीक है ना तो देखो य पर एमपी
आईडी ए नेम मेरे सामने लिखकर आया है ठीक
है तो ऐसा रहता है अपना सेलेक्ट के साथ
में अगर ओनली कॉलम्स भी स्पेसिफाई कर सकते
हैं कि यार अपन को कौन से कौन से कॉलम
चाहिए नहीं तो डाल के सारे के सारे कॉलम्स
भी देख सकते हैं ठीक है वो कोई टेंशन लेने
वाली बात नहीं अपने
पास ठीक
है तो एक अपनी य पर हो
गई तो यह डिफरेंट कॉलम्स के थ्रू एंड ऐसे
य दो तरीके हैं जिसकी अ देख सकते हैं
सेलेट केर और भी चीज है अभी अपन देखेंगे
हा तो देखो अब है ना ये अपना मैं खोल लेता
हूं हां अपना नेक्स्ट आता है अपना वेयर
क्लॉज वेयर क्लॉज कंडीशन की तरह रहता है
मतलब जैसे अपन प्रोग्रामिंग के अंदर
कंडीशंस का इस्तेमाल करते हैं ना तो वैसे
इसके अंदर भी कंडीशन का इस्तेमाल करते
हैं गलत कर दिया क्या मैंने आपका
नाम क्या अ सॉरी सॉरी टेंशन नहीं करो यार
मैंने जान पूछ के किया गलत ठीक है अपन आगे
जाकर इस नाम को सही कैसे करेंगे व भी अपन
देखने वाले सो डोंट वरी टा गलत कैसे होता
है उसको सही करना भी देखेंगे आगे सो टेंशन
नहीं करो अच्छा वसे आपने बता भी
दिया हा तुम अगर मुझे मान लो इन डटा में
से चाए सि वही डटा जिन डटा का अपना मतलब
जिन वैल्यूज का सैलरी अपना 80000 से ऊपर
हो ताकि वो 80000 के जूते खरीद सके ठीक है
अब हमको वो चाहिए तो अगर मैं य पर लिखू आर
सेलेक्ट स्टार
फ्रॉम एप्ल
वेर
सैलरी इक्वल
टू 80
हज तो देखो न इक्व कर दिया ज्यादा चाहिए
तो सबसे इ समता कर दिया तो देख
वेर के साथन कंडीशन लगाते हैं कंडीशन देखो
इसके ऐसे रहते है अपन कॉलम का नेम देना
रहता है फ जा वैल्यू के बीच में ऑपरेटर
लगाना रहता है ठीक है ना ये जस्ट वैसा ही
इ कंडीशन रहती है प्रोग्रामिंग लो के लिए
कंडीशन रहती है य डालते यार अगर डबल इक्वल
टू इस्तेमाल करते हैं व देखो इसके सिंगल
इक्व ू का मतलब असाइनमेंट नहीं
है ठीक है ये यहा पर सिंगल य ड इ नहीं
लगेगा अपने कंपेरिजन के लिए य सिंगल इवल
टू हील
लगता है अपना कंपेरिजन के लिए डबल इक्व
नहीं लगता डबल इ प्रोग्राम के अंदर ल क्यक
व सिंगल इक्वल टू अपना जो रहता है व
असाइनमेंट ऑपरेटर बन जाता है लेकिन य
असाइनमेंट का नहीं करते य वलू इनपुट कर
रहे य कुछ न किसी को असाइन नहीं कर रहे
जाकर ठीक हैसे कोई वेरिएबल वेरिएबल नहीं
बना रहे ठीक है पील एल के अंदर वेरिएबल
बनाने का रहता है लेकिन उसके अर भी इ नहीं
लगता है उसके अंदर कॉलन इक्व लगता है प के
अंदर रकल के अंदर ही है इसलिए अपट अपन
यहां पे मल्टीपल के हिसाब से करेंगे तो
पीएल एएल अपने कोर्स में नहीं रहेगा बट
अगर आपको ओनली पीएल एसक्यूएल सीखना रहेगा
तो आप इस कोर्स के बाद में जरूर बताइएगा
कि पीएल एसक्यूएल का भी डिमांड है तो उस
हिसाब से देखेंगे कि क्या करने का है उसके
आगे ठीक है हां तो अभी देखो मैंने यहां पे
इक्वल्स टू ऑपरेटर देखो ऑपरेटर्स वगैरह
बहुत इजी से रहते है य सिंगल मतलब इक्वल्स
टू का मतलब समझ ही र अगर सैलरी 80000 के
इक्वल हुई तो अपने को ये वैल्यूज लाके
देगा ठीक है तो जिन जिन का सैलरी 80000 के
इक्वल है य देखो इधर इधर दिख रहागा जिनका
सैलरी 80000 के इक्वल है ठीक है ना तो
उन्होने उसका डाटा लाक दे दिया ठीक है अब
डाटा कैसे लाके दिया स्टार को देख के किया
सब कुछ लाके देने का अगर मैं यहां पर
स्टार की जगह पर वो लिख देता हूं अपना
जैसे मुझे य ओनली ईम पी आईडी एंड नेम
चाहिए ठीक है ना तो वैसे आ जाएगा य लिखा
हुआ कि इन दो का ही है जरूरी नहीं है मैं
एमपी आईडी ने लिख य नेम और एमपी आईडी भी
कर सकता हं तो उस अकॉर्डिंग य पर डटा आएगा
नेम और एम आई ठीक है तो देखो य प नेम लिख
आया फर आ लिख मतलब आप ची के पीछे कांसेप्ट
ठीक है
ना नहीं 80000 की 8 के नहीं लिख सकते 80
के एक स्ट्रिंग हो जाएगा ठीक है ना 800 एक
अपना 80000 मतलब एक अपना वो रहेगा क्या
कहते अपना एक इंजर एक नंबर रहेगा इजर नंबर
रहेगा एक इंटी जर भी है वो हा एक नंबर
रहेगा इसलिए अपन यहां पर ऐसे लिखते हैं
ताकि क्या है ना कल को अगर अगर को कल को
अगर अपने को कोई ऑपरेशन करना रहा उस
ऑपरेशन के वक्त में चीजें अपने को इजी
निकल के आती है
बाहर ठीक है ना ब्रेक लोज का काम क्या है
कंडीशंस लगाना अपने उसके अंदर टेबल के
अंदर ठीक है ना और बाकी फिर और बाकी फिर
अपन नेक्स्ट जाते हैं अपने ऑपरेटर्स की
तरफ में ये इतने टाइप के ऑपरेटर्स रहते
हैं जो आपको सामने य पर दिख रहे हैं मैं
एक बार मेरा पेन लिखा देता
ये देखो स्लाइड इतनी जल्दी चेंज हो रही है
इसका मतलब ये नहीं समझना कि थोड़ जल्दी
जल्दी चलाया जा रहा है इस कोर्स को ऐसा
बात नहीं है इस स्लाइड है अ य जल्दी आपको
लग रही होगी लेकिन हकीकत में आगे जब
जाएंगे तो आपको समझ आएगा कब क्लास एक घंटे
की हो गई
है तो देखो यहां पर एक मैंने इक्व के बारे
में बताया अभी यह भी अपन देखेंगे ठीक है
ना इसको अभी के लिए थोड़ा स्किप करेंगे
बाद में देखेंगे फिर अपन ये देखेंगे ये
देखेंगे एंड
बिटवीन शायद आज ना देखें लाइक भी अपन आज
नहीं देखेंगे इन शायद आज देखें ठीक है ये
ये तीन आज तभी करेंगे जब अपने पास टाइम
बचेगा टाइम नहीं रहा तो फिर नहीं करेंगे
इसको आज अपन आगे बट ये ऐसा नहीं समझना किय
कवर नहीं कराया जा रहा कवर कराया जाएगा
ठीक है
ना तो उसका टेंशन मत करना आप लोग सब कुछ
एकदम यहां पर पूरा कोर्स सेट हो रखा है
ठीक है
ना जो बच्चे लोग बीसीए कर रहे हैं उनका तो
पूरा कोर्स मॉड्यूल ही यही है
ठीक है हां तो एक मैंने इक्व बता दिया अब
मान लो कि मैं ना अगर सैलरी मुझे चाहिए कि
ज्यादा हो 80000 से ठीक है ना उन लोगों का
मुझे सब कुछ निकल के आए तो य सेलेक्ट
स्टार कर
दूंगा स्टार वे सैलरी ग्रेटर देन देखो
मैंने लास्ट सेशन में आपको बताया था इस
चीज को लेकर कि यार ये ब्लैक कलर में
वाइट
वाइट ठीक है ना
मैंने आपको लास्ट से में बताया था कि देख
सिंपल इंग्लिश सेलेक्ट करो सब कुछ कहां से
फ्रॉम एंप्लॉई सेट करो सब कुछ एंप्लॉई में
से वेर मतलब जहां पर देखो सिंपल ये
इंग्लिश को हिंदी में कन्वर्ट कर लो जहां
पर अपना सैलरी
हो ज्यादा 80000 से ठीक है ना एक दो बार
आप करोगे तो इस चीजों का समझ में आएगा
यहां पर देखो सेलेक्ट करो नाम और एमपी
आईडी अपना एंप्लॉई में से
जहां पर सैलरी 80000 के इक्वल
हो ठीक है नर्मल अपना इंग्लिश की तरह चल
रहा है देखा
तो पूरा इंग्लिश पर बेस्ड है ठीक है ना
छोटा म चीज थो सिंटेक्स जाते अपन बट दे तो
थ इंग्लिश की तरह तो आप एक दो बार करने
बैठोगे ना तो य हो जाएगा मतलब इजी सा रहता
है ठीक
है हां तो देखो अभी जिनका सैलरी 80000 से
ऊपर था सिर्फ वो लोग दिख रहे है यहां पर
आपको दिख रहा है ना सब कुछ ये देखो यहां
पर अगर अपन देखें तो ये आपको दिख रहा
रहेगा यहां पर देखो 800 के इक्वल आ रहा था
जब अपने यहां प इक्वल ट का इस्तेमाल किया
था एंड यहां प जब अपन यहां पर ग्रेटर देन
का यूज कर रहे हैं तो अपना ये वाला आया
अपने
सामने ठीक है होप आप लोगों को समझ में आ
रहा रहेगा वेयर क्या करता है अपना कंडीशन
डालने का काम होता है कंडीशन में अपन यहां
पर कॉलम का नेम डालते हैं ठीक है ना कॉलम
का नेम के साथ में अपन यहां पर
अ वो डालते हैं क्या कहते हैं ऑपरेटर
डालते हैं फिर यहां प वैल्यू डालते हैं अब
देखो अगर मैं अभी तो मुझे बताना चाहिए
नहीं बट फिर भी आप लोगों का थोड़ा
इंटरेस्ट जगे कि एसल को लेकर साइबर
सिक्योरिटी से रिलेटेड तो मैं आपको बताता
हूं कि यार देखो यह जो चीज है ना यह जो
वेर वाला जो चीज है ना य
वेयर यही आपका वेबसाइट पर जाकर लॉग इन
आईडी पासवर्ड वगैरे जाकर चेक करता है आ
रही है बात समझ में
बर के अंदर ही अपन डालते हैं लॉगिन आईडी
और पासवर्ड अपना ठीक है ना एंड यहां पर ही
अपन आगे
ऐसी इंजेक्ट अगर देखो अगर अपना वापस
इंजेक्शन होता है ना वेबसाइट के अंदर तो
अपन यह कंडीशन में ऐसे चेंस कर कर पाते
हैं जिसके वजह से अपन उसका ऑलवेज ट्रू
आउटपुट लेकर आ जाते हैं जिसकी वजह से क्या
होता है वो टेबल की सारी की सारी वैल्यूज
अपने को सामने दे देता
है ठीक है यह अपना एसल इंजेक्शन का लॉजिक
होता है वेर के आगे की जो कंडीशन होती है
ना इसको अपन को ट्रू करवाना रहता
है ठीक है जैसे ही अपन इस कंडीशन को ट्रू
करवा देते हैं ट्रू करवाने के बाद में यह
सारा टेबल का वैल्यू लाके दे देगा अगर
वहां पर एस इंजेक्शन पॉसिबिलिटी हुई तो
ठीक है ऐसे अपना किसी भी वेबसाइट के अंदर
इजेक्शन काम करता है
ओनली इतना ही नहीं है उसके अर और भी चीजें
है जैसे जसे डीप जाएंगे वैसे वैसे मैंने
आपको बेसिक दिया जिस से सीख रहे हो अभी उस
हिसाब से मैंने आपको इस चीज को बेसिक
दिया होप आप लोगों को समझ में आ रहा रहेगा
क्या आपको भी एल पढ़ने का नीड क्यों हो
रहा है अगर आपको इंजेक्शन के अंदर अच्छे
से मास्टरी करनी हो म मास्टरी तो मतलब अगर
आपको अच्छे सेर इंजेक्शन को समझना
हो ठीक है
तो वैसे ही अप लेसन भी कर सकते
हैं 800 से नीचे बस यह कृष्णा पुरोहित भाई
का है
600 ठीक है आप लोग को सम बो तो नहीं लग
रहा कुछ यार क्या करा रहे हो भाई आप कुछ
भी करा रहे हो क्या ऐसे तो किसी को नहीं
लग रहा ना य
पर अपना सेम वैसा ही मतलब ग्रेटर देन
इक्वल टू भी अपन लगा सकते है इसके अंदर
क्या होगा अपना 80000 भी इंक्लूड हुआ 85
भी इंक्लूड 80000 भी इंक्लूड हु 900 भी
इंक्लूड हु लेकिन 6 इंक्लूड नहीं
हुआ ठीक है ना ये 600 यहां प इंक्लूड नहीं
हुआ
क्योंकि ये अपनी कंडीशन के अंदर नहीं आता
है ये जो अपनी कंडीशन है इसके अंदर 6 कहीं
सेटिस्फाई नहीं हो इसकी वजह
से ठीक है व अगर मैं स्लर देन इक्वल टू कर
दूंगा तो यहां पर 600 आएगा 80000 भी आएगा
इक्वल्स टू भी लगा हुआ है एंड लेस देन भी
लगा हुआ है ठीक
है तो ऐसा अपना ये काम करता है ठीक है
अलग-अलग ऑपरेटर्स हो ग ठीक है अब भाई मुझे
है ना मोहम्मद कैफ भाई को मेरे से बहुत
शिकायत हैं कि यार मैंने उनका नाम गलत डाल
दिया है तो चलो उनका नाम सही करने चलते
हैं ठीक है तो अगर अपन से डाटा में अपन को
चेंजेज करने होते हैं तो उस केस में अपन
क्या यूज करते हैं मैं प्रेजेंटेशन के
हिसाब से चलते हैं अपन आगे ठीक है
अपडेट कमांड का मॉडिफाई टेबल
रिकर्ड
य पर टेबल के रिकॉर्ड अगर मॉडिफाई करने
रहे तो य पर कंड
अपडेट टेबल
नेम
एप्ल सेट करना
है नेम
में
म कैफ
ठीक
है कहां पर करना है
वेयर ईम पी
आईडी इक्वल्स टू इनका ईम पी आईडी क्या है
मैं एक बार य पर दिखाता हूं सेलेक्ट स्टार
फम ठीक है यहां पर देखो मोमद कैद करके लिख
दिया मैंने सॉरी भाई मतलब नो
ठीक
है तो मैंने य पर ऐसे करके लिख दिया है तो
र एमपी आईडी इक्ट
ठीक वन रो अपडेटेड अब जाके चेक करते यह
देखो मोहम्मद क भाई का भाई का कैद हो गया
ने सही करके कै कर दिया सही तो कर दिया
भाई आपका मतलब अभी तो कोई आपको मेरे से
दिक्कत नहीं है ना मतलब अगर आपको लग रही
हो
तो तो ऐसे अपन इसके अंदर चीजें अपडेट करते
हैं कैसे पहले लिखते अपडेट टेबल नेम सेट
करना है कॉलम का नेम इक्वल टू वैल्यू फिर
अपन लिखते य कंडीशन वेर ये मतलब य पर अपन
कंडीशन देनी है वोन कंडीशन लिख देते है अब
देखो ऐसा नहीं है कि अपन ने ना इसके अंदर
वैसे ही करते हैं
कि अपने एमपी आईडी के हिसाब से अपन चल रहे
हैं ऐसा नहीं है जो आप कंडीशन दोगे ना
उसके हिसाब से जाएगा या आप कंडीशन नहीं
दोगे हर जगह चला जाएगा हर जगह वैल्यू चेंज
रहेगी लेकिन आप अगर आप ऐसा चाहो कि यार
मुझे सैलरी सेट करनी
है सबको नेटवर्क एक्सप्लो से फील हो रहा
है
क्या
[संगीत]
कि नेटवर्क तो थोड़ा सही सही लग रहा है
देखकर सबको इशू आ रहा है क्या नेटवर्क के
अंदर प्लीज मुझ चैट में बताओ सबको इश आ
रहा है क्या नेटवर्क के
अंदर सर मतलब मेरा कनेक्टिविटी कैसा आ रहा
है
चलो नो रिप्लाई अभी तक चलो कोई बात नहीं
तो अगर देखो मान लो कि मुझे इसके ऐसी
कंडीशन देनी है कि यार जिनका सैलरी है ना
अपना 80000 से नीचे है ठीक है ना उन सबका
सैलरी 1000 कर
दो
ठीक है तो उस केस में क्या करूंगा मैं य
पर लिख अपडेट एंप्लॉई सेट सैलरी इक्वल टू
70000 वेर सैलरी इक्वल टू नहीं सैलरी इ
लेसन 80000 इस केस में अपन क्या कर रहे है
ना अपन अपडेट कर रहे हैं एप्ल टेबल के
अंदर एंड सेट कर रहे हैं सैलरी 1000 सबकी
जिनकी सैलरी 80000 से कम है मतलब अप सबको
प्रमोशन दे रहे हैं क्या भाई तुम यार इतना
अच्छा काम कर रहे हो री सैलरी सब सबकी कम
लग रही है सबका मैं 177000 कर दूंगा तो वन
अपडेट हुआ वन अपडेट इसलिए दिखा रहा है
यहां पे क्योंकि सिर्फ एक ही बंदा है
जिनका सैलरी 600 से कम है वो है कृष्णा
पुरोहित भाई का ठीक है ना सॉरी भाई मेरी
कोई आपसे दुश्मनी नहीं है लेकिन फिर भी
दिखाना था इसलिए मैंने ऐसा किया तो देखो
इनके 17000 हो गया अगर ऐसे और रिकर्ड होते
ना तो सबका ऐसा चेंस हो
जाता ठीक है तो ऐसे अपना अपडेट काम करता
कंडीशन देती आपको किस कंडीशन के हिसाब से
आपको आगे चलने का है एंड फिर वैसे ही अपना
चलता है अपडेट के अंदर ठीक है ना कहीं भी
टा में दिक्कत दिक्कत होती है तो इस चीजों
को अपन ऐसे हील
कर ठीक
है कोई बात नहीं भाई सभी लोग चले गए
तो
अब अपन देखते हैं फंक्शंस ठीक है ना ऐसे
मतलब फंक्शंस आप कस्टम भी खुद के बना सकते
हो ठीक है ना वो शायद मुझे फीचर माय स् का
तो आईडिया नहीं लेकिन ओरेकल के अंदर बना
सकते अपन ठीक है
ना बट अभी अपन जो इसके प्री डिफाइंड
फंक्शन है सिर्फ वही देखेंगे जिसमें से
कुछ फंक्शन हमने काउंट है एवरेज है सम है
मिनिमम है मैक्सिमम है ठीक है ना तो अपन
इस फंक्शंस का इस्तेमाल कैसे करते हैं अभी
अपन यहां देखेंगे अभी देखो अगर मुझे काउंट
करना है कि
यार मेरे कितने एंप्लॉयज है ठीक है ना तो
मैं क्या लिखूंगा ना यहां पर लिखूंगा
सेलेक्ट
काउंट ईम पी
आईडी ईपी आईडी
फ्रॉम एप्ल
काउंट पाच अपने पास सभी पांच ही काउंट में
एक दो तीन च पा इसलिए य अपन को य काउंट के
अंदर इसने दिया है पा ठीक है अब देखो इसका
एक फीचर आपको बताता हूं क्या रहता है देखो
अगर अपन काउंट के अंदर अभी मैंने ए आईडी
दिया य पर ए आईडी सारे भरे हुए हैं ठीक है
ना अगर इनमें से कोई भी एक के अंदर वैल्यू
नहीं होता ना तो यहां पर यहां पर एक काउंट
कम हो
जाता मैं का करता आपको एग्जांपल के साथ ही
दिखा देता हूं मैंने
शायद कांटेक्ट नंबर य फोन वाला था इसके
अंदर काम करता
इर्ट
इनटू
एई
वैल्यू
सॉरी
106 ये ओपी बट भाई का डाल देते
बट ठीक है और फिर अपन हा अभी देखो मुझे
कोई वैल्यू जरा खाली छोड़नी है तो मैं
यहां पर ऐसे य पर नल लिखकर ऐसे काम नहीं
कर सकता हूं ठीक है यहां पर ऐसे खाली छोड़
के भी काम नहीं कर सकता हूं शायद मैंने एक
बार किया था बट मुझे उसका ढंग से याद नहीं
आ रहा बट फिर भी अपन एक ट्रेडिशनल वे के थ
अगर इसको फॉलो करें तो अपन को य कॉलम्स
लिखने पड़ते हैं ठीक है तो एमपी आईडी कॉमा
नेम कॉमा स्टेट भरने का है स्टेट अगर मैं
नहीं भंगा तो अपने राजस्थान ले लेगा तो
मैं स्टेड ने देता हूं एंड सैलरी भर देता
हूं ठीक है तो यहां पर मैंने यहां पर लिख
दिया अपना य प इस सीक्वेंस के हिसाब से
लिख दिया इंसर्ट के अंदर अगर मैं य पर
सीक्वेंस नहीं डालता हूं तो मतलब यह बाय
डिफॉल्ट सीक्वेंस के हिसाब से ही चलेगा जो
यहां पर है उस सीक्वेंस को म देखना तो
डीसी अपन करके लिखेंगे वो जिस सीक्वेंस
में रहेगा वो उसी सीक्वेंस से अपन को डाटा
डालना रहेगा जब अपन यहां पर कॉलम
स्पेसिफाई नहीं कर रहे हैं तो बट अगर अपन
यहां पर कॉलम स्पेसिफाई कर रहे हैं तो उस
केस के अंदर क्या
अपन को य पर यहां पर जो अपन ने सीक्वेंस
डाली है उस सीक्वेंस के हिसाब से टा डालना
रहेगा ठीक है तो अभी अपने ईम पी आईडी य पर
डाला ईम पी आईडी डालने के बाद में अपने य
नेम डाला ठीक है अब अपन डालेंगे सेरी अपने
देखो मैंने य पर पाच अपने कॉलम थे जिसके
अंदर से मैंने सिर्फ य तीन डाले क्योंकि य
फोन को मैं नल छोड़ सकता हूं ठीक है ना
मैंने कंडीशन ऐसी दे रखी है मतलब
कांस्टेंट मैंने ऐसे दे रखे है इसके अंदर
एक क्वेश्चन रुद्र रुद्रा रुद्रा भाई आप
पूछते जाओ मैं जैसे ही देखूंगा मैं आपको
रिप्लाई कर दूंगा आप बस अपना क्वेश्चन लिख
दो ठीक
है डाउट्स आर गुड ट मींस की यू आर
स्टडिंग सर वेबसाइट के बैक एंड में
एसक्यूएल डेटाबेस होता है इसमें आप
वेबसाइट भी बनाकर बताएंगे जिसे लॉग इन कर
सकता है
कोई भाई ये बाद की बात है पहले अपन यह
देखते
हैं ब समझते हैं अगर टाइम रहा अगर मुझे
अच्छा रिस्पांस लगा सीरियसली बताऊं तो अ ब
अच्छे खासे लोग आ रहे रहेंगे तो मैं जरूर
ट्राई करूंगा यह पूरा एसम ऐसे करने
का वेबसाइट बनाकर एसक्यूएल का सर्वर चालू
करके लोकल उस में मैं जरूर बनाने का ट्राई
करूंगा बस थोड़ा मोटिवेशन मे यार आप लोग
आते हो मतलब ऐसे लाइव अटेंड करते हो या
फिर आप कुछ भी कमेंट करते हो अच्छा या
बुरा कैसा भी कमेंट कर रहे हो तो उससे एक
है ना मोटिवेशन सी मिलती है काम को करने
की कि यार काम काम करना चाहिए इन लोगों के
लिए य अपने सपोर्ट में खड़े हैं एनी टाइम
24/7 ठीक है तो जितने ज्यादा लोग सपोर्ट
में रहते हैं ना उतने ज्यादा कॉन्फिडेंट
मिलता है कि अगर यार कोई चीज का अगर करने
का मन नहीं भी है या फिर कुछ चीजों का ऐसा
है कि यार मतलब नहीं भी आता होगा मेरे को
ना तो भी अगर आप लोगों के से मुझे अच्छा
रिस्पांस आएगा ना मैं आपको गारंटी लिख
देता हूं यहां पर मैं आपको सीख करव करके
लाके
दूंगा ठीक है ना अगर आपको किसी और चीज की
डिमांड है ना आप डिमांड डालो ठीक है ना
अगर डिमांड सबको अच्छी लगेगी ना सीरियसली
बता रहा हूं मैं उसको सीख कर य पर आपको
सिखाने को राजी
हूं ठीक
है लिनिक्स के अंदर आपको करने के लिए आप
मेरी फाइल डाउनलोड मत करना क्योंकि वो
फाइल एक्ससी फाइल है ् फाइल से विंडोज में
चलेगी आपके ठीक है ना वैसे आप वाइन का यूज
करके अपना उसके अंदर भी आप l के अंदर भी
आप रन कर सकते हो लेकिन लि के अंदर एल का
आपको सर्वर चालू करके और ल भी आप कर सकते
हो गल करोगे हाउ टू इंस्टॉल ओकल एसल सर्वर
ऑन लिनिक्स लोकल होस्ट तो आपको बहुत पता
लग जाएगा एक बार आपने कनेक्ट कर लिया ना
अपने लोकल हो से एल को तो उसके बाद में जो
मैंने य पर कमांड वगैरह बता रहा हूं ना
वही कमांड आपके वहां पर भी रहेगी कोई चेंस
नहीं होंगे कमांड के अंदर ठीक है ना बस इट
जस्ट अबाउट इंस्टॉलेशन सर्वर के अंदर आपको
जैसे मैंने फइल ऐ इंस्टॉलेशन नहीं होता है
वो आपको वैसे ही इंस्टॉलेशन करना पड़ेगा
उस वक्त
में ठीक
है कमांड लाइन के थ्रू ठीक है तो यहां पे
मैंने 106 ओ वड करके यहां प इनका सैलरी
में काम करता हूं कि इनका 95000 डाल देता
हूं ठीक है तो मेरे कांस्टेंट्स के हिसाब
से मैंने यहां पर वैल्यूज इनपुट किया
है एक रो इंसर्ट हो गई है ठीक है ना आप
सेलेक्ट स्ट ठीक है अब अब मैं आपको ना ये
देखो ये ओनली काउंट के साथ नहीं है ये
अधिकतर हर फ के साथ में रहता है य पर देखो
मैंने य फोन के अंदर एक भाई का मैंने फोन
नंबर नहीं डाला य पर ठीक है ना यहां पर
मैंने स्ट भी नहीं डाला था लेकिन राजन आ
गया क्योंकि मैंने व पर अपने कांस्टेंट के
अर डिफॉल्ट दे रखा है स्ट डाल दो ठीक है
तो ै य पर रहेगा अब देखो अगर मैं य पर
काउंट करता
हूं कहां गया
या
हा काउंट करता य प
फोन से ठीक है नहीं अगर मैं य पहले ईम पी
आईडी से काउंट करूंगा तो देखो एमपी आईडी
के अंदर अभी सब कुछ छ का छह है यहां पर तो
इसने काउंट भी य पर छ दिखा दिया अगर य पर
अगर फोन लिखूंगा यहां
पर तो य पर पांच ही दिखाया इसको ऐसे क्यों
क्योंकि अपन ने यहां पर एक वैल्यू नल छोड़
रखी है ठीक है ना एक वैल्यू खाली छोड़ रखा
है इसलिए यहां पर इसने काउंट पाच ही
दिखाया अभी एमपी आईडी के अंदर कोई भी
वैल्यू खाली नहीं है तो इसने यहां पर अपना
सब कुछ दिखा दिया ठीक है तो देखो एक चीज
मैं आपको बताता हूं अगर ऐसा कुछ आपका
सिनेरियो बनता है कि आपके पास नल वैल्यू
है तो आपको है ना उस केस में क्या करना
पड़ता है ना आपको य पर काउंट में स्टार दे
देने का य स्टार दोगे ना तो यह ना नल
वैल्यू को भी काउंट करेगा एंड य पर आपको
टोटल काउंट लाके दे देगा कि कितने रोज
आपके पास है चाहे व नल ही क्यों ना हो ठीक
है
भाई एसक्यूएल की इंस्टॉलेशन या माय
एसक्यूएल यह सवाल थोड़ा बैठा नहीं माय एल
के अंदर भी एसल ही होता है ओरेकल के अंदर
भी एल ही होता है ठीक है ना तो मतलब आप
थोड़ा सवाल गलत पूछ रहे हो मेरे ख्याल से
या फिर आपको कहने का मतलब कुछ और है एसल
दोनों में ही रहता है तो आप इंस्टॉल कुछ
भी कर सकते हो माय स् भी कर सकते हो ओरेकल
भी कर सकते हो लेकिन अभी मैं य ओरेकल आपको
पढ़ा रहा हूं डीली तो आप ओरेकल ही मैं
प्रेफर करूंगा बट आप जो ये कमांड है वो हर
जगह चला सकते हो कुछ छोटे मोटे चेंजेज है
जो मैं आपको वर्ली बता रहा हूं किय चेंस
रहते हैं होप
फुली ठीक
है तो अगर आपको अभी साथ साथ में चलना है
तो आप कंफ्यूज होगे माय एल को डाउनलोड
करके तो आप मेरे ख्याल से ओरेकल ही
करो ठीक है हां तो देखो मैंने य स्टार
लगाने के बाद यहां प सिक्स कर दिया है तो
इस चीज का ध्यान रखना नल वैल्यू आपके पास
रहे तो आप स्टार का इस्तेमाल करोगे तो फिर
आपको सब कुछ वो काउंट करके देगा चाहे
वैल्यू नल ही क्यों ना हो तो काउंट के
अंदर नल का ही स्टार का इस्तेमाल करना ठीक
है तो एक अपना काउंट हो गया अब ना ऐसे और
भी लेते जैसे मैं मैं चाहता हूं कि मैं ये
सबको सैलरी दे रहा हूं अब मेरे को इनका
एवरेज पता करना है क्या मैं यार एवरेज
सैलरी कितनी दे रहा हूं सबको एवरेज सैलरी
क्या है तो मैं उसके लिए करूंगा
सेलेक्ट
एवीजी सैलरी
फॉम ठीक है ना अब ये ना इसने इस पूरे का
एवरेज निकाल के एवरेज सैलरी कितनी दे रहा
तो एवरेज सैलरी में
83333 सैलरी दे रहा
हूं ठीक
है तो यह एवरेज अपन को यहां पर निकल के
मिल
गया अब वैसा अपना मिनिमम भी रता है मुझे
मान लो मिनिमम सैलरी पता करनी हो तो मैं
मिन लिख दूंगा तो मिनिमम सैलरी 700 है ठीक
है ना मैं अगर चाहूं कि मैक्सिमम मुझे
सैलरी निकालनी है तो य पर मैक्स भी लिख
सकता हूं मैक्सिमम सैलरी लिख करर आ जाएगा
अपना ठीक है ना ऐसे और क्या क्या हैने इस
हा एव मिनिमम अगर सारी सैलरी का सम करने
मुझे पता करने मेरी जेब से कितना जा रहा
है या सारे को लेकर तो मैं य पर सम कर
दूंगा तो यार मैं 5 लाख रुप नहीं कि हा 5
लाख रुप दे रहा हूं अभी सबको
सैलरी ठीक है मैंस देखो नहीं है स नहीं दे
सता फिर भी अपन लिखने में कुछ नहीं जाता
अपने
को हा अब देखो यार आपको अगर ऐसा लग रहा है
क्या सम सैलरी मैक्स सैलरी मीन सैलरी
एवरेज सैलरी य लिखा हुआ आपको अच्छा नहीं
लग रहा यार ये जो लिखा हुआ है ना ये मेरे
को ना आपको अपने हिसाब से चाहिए तो मैं
इसके लिए क्या कर सकता हूं
ना देखो जैसे अगर मेरे
को देखो अगर मैं एवरेज सैलरी का खाना चाहू
तो यहां पर लिख दूंगा
एस एवी ई आर आ जी एवरेज ठीक है इससे क्या
होगा ना एज लिखने के बाद में यहां प मैं
इसको जो मैंने य एवरेज लिखा इसको बोलते है
अलाइज नेम ठीक है ना मैं यहां पर खुद का
नेम डालने के लिए मुझे य अलाइज नेम डालना
पड़ेगा तो उसके लिए मुझे लिखना पड़ेगा
सेलेक्ट जो फंक्शन में य पर रन कर रहा हूं
एस य प अलाज नेम फ्रॉम
एप्ल ठीक है ना ये अला नेम जरूरी नहीं कि
मैं फंक्शन के साथ ही करू जब आप यहां पर
अपना वो इस्तेमाल करते
हो कॉलम्स का इस्तेमाल करते हो तो उस
कॉलम्स के वक्त में भी आप य पर कस्टम कॉलम
की नेम य आउटपुट में दिखा सकते हो आप मुझे
यह ट्राई करके दिखाओगे एंड मुझे
स्क्रीनशॉट दोगे मैं आपको टा में य चीज
जरूर दूंगा ठीक है ना ए यूल ज टा देते हैं
वैसे ही चलेगा सब कुछ ठीक है तो ऐसे अपने
फंक्शन होते हैं ऐसे और भी बहुत से फंक्शन
होते हैं आपको फंक्शन भी मुझे पता करके
बताने ट्राई करके दिखाने हैं ठीक
है
यना फंक्शन हो गया पट हो गया अब अगर मुझे
इसके बाद क्या
है ठीक
है पहले ऑर्डर बाय कर लेते हैं डिलीट अपन
बाद में कर लेंगे ड के बाद
में पले डर बाय कर
लेते अब मान लो
की सेलेक्ट स्टार
फ्रॉम या देखो ऐसा नहीं कि स्लाइड मैं
नहीं बनाता हूं तो मेरे को देखना पड़ रहा
है कि आगे क्या है मैंने स्लाइड मतलब पहले
बना ली थी तो इस चकर के अंदर मैं भूल गया
इसका
सीक्वेंस इसलिए मैंने एक बार सोचा कि एक
बार चेक कर लेता हूं कि क्या सीक्वेंस
है अब देखो यार मैं चाहता हूं कि मेरा जो
आउटपुट है वो अपना अल्फाबेटिकली आए नेम
वाला जो है य नेम मेरे को अल्फाबेटिकली
चाहिए तो उस से मैं क्या लिखूंगा ना य प
लिखूंगा
सेलेक्ट स्टार
फ्रॉम
एंप्लॉई ऑर्डर बाय
नेम तो देखो ऑर्डर बाय नेम लिखने के बाद
में नेम के हिसाब से यह असेंडिंग ऑर्डर
में आके यहां पर दिख गया है अपने को ठीक
है ना पहले बी आया
के एम ओ आ ठीक है ऐसे करके अपन को यहां पर
दिखाया ठीक है नेम के हिसाब से इसने डरिंग
करर आ असेंडिंग डर में कन्वर्ट करना है तो
अपन इसको ऐसे असेंडिंग ऑर्डर में कन्वर्ट
करते काम करता कमांड लिख देता पता लगे आप
से कुछ लोग अच्छे टास्क कर रहे हो तो उनको
नोट देने पड़े तो उसके लिए उन लोगों के
लिए य इ करने के लिए कर रहा
हूं
इसको यार जो लोग मेहनत कर रहे हैं उनका
यार उनका तो सपोर्ट डेफिनेटली जरूर करता
है जो लोग मेहनत करते हैं ठीक
है तो अगर मुझे मान लो कि है ना ऑर्डरिंग
उसी के ही हिसाब से करनी
है जिनका सैलरी अपना 800 से ऊपर हो तो व
भी कर सकते हैं मैंने कभी ट्राई किया नहीं
फर्स्ट टाइम ु ट्राई कर रहा हूं सैलरी गटर
8 ठीक है शायद इसके साथ में वेर नहीं लगता
हैक कर
लेता हा इसके में ड नहीं लगता है सॉरी गा
इस नहीं लगता है अगर आप चाहो ंग तो नहीं
हो सकता है पूरा उसी का ही रहता है एंड
हा हा इसको करने के बाद में मैं आपको य पर
दिखाता हूं कि अगर मुझे मान लो कि ओनली
कस्टम कुछ कुछ ने चाहिए तो भी अप य पर कर
सकते
हैसे एमपी आईडी या देखो ना कस्टम अपना
कस्टम क्या सिलेक्टेड रोज अगर अपन को कॉलम
अगर अपन को दिखाने है तो व हर जगह पॉसिबल
रहता है अपना ठीक है ना यहां पर मैंने
सिलेक्टेड रोज दिखा दिए हैं ठीक है ना
जरूरी नहीं है कि नेम का इंक्लूड होना
जरूरी है नेम अगर इंक्लूड नहीं भी होगा ना
तो भी अपन तो भी अपना टा की डाटा की जो
ऑर्डरिंग है वो नेम के हिसाब से ही होगी
जैसे अगर मैं चाहू कि ईपी आईडी एंड सैलरी
दिखाऊ ठीक है ना तो आप देख पाओगे कि यहां
पर एमपी आईडी की ऑर्डरिंग देखना ये वैसा
ही हुआ है जैसा अपना नेम का अपन ने ऑर्डर
किया था ठीक है ना बी पहले है तो उसका 105
है तो यहां पर 105 आया फिर के आया तो 104
तो 104 ठीक है
तो जरूरी नहीं है कि आप जिस चीज को लेकर
अपना आउटपुट चाहते हो उस चीज को भी क्लूड
करना ठीक लाइक मैं क्या कहना चाहता हूं कि
अगर आपको नेम के हिसाब से सर्ट करनी है
ठीक है बट आपको नेम ही नहीं चाहिए अपने
आउटपुट के अंदर वह चीज भी पॉसिबल है ठीक
है ऐसा मत सम व पॉसिबल नहीं व चीज भी
पॉसिबल रता
है तो अगर अभी
आडी हो गया
है थोड़ा सा अभी अपने पास 10 मिनट का और
वक्त है तो अभी अपन एक काम करते हैं वेर
को थोड़ा सा और में एक्सेंड करता ठीक है
सेलेक्ट स्टार
फम य साइड के अंदर नहीं था बट यह चीज
बतानी जरूरी है ठीक है आप लोगों ने
प्रोग्रामिंग के अंदर एंड और व इस्तेमाल
किया रहेगा ठीक है ना कौन कन प्रोग्रामिंग
जानता है या मुझे एक बार चैट में एक पिन
कर दो क्या प्रोग्रामिंग आती है भाई मेरे
को
थोड़ी बहुत सिक्स
के य पर यार मैं एक और टा डाल देता मुझे
टा डले अच्छे नहीं लग
रहे ब
देखो अगर आप कमांड देख के अगर समझ पा रहे
रहेंगे कि यार पुराने पहले भी इस्तेमाल
किए गए हैं मतलब लास्ट सेशन में भी कराए
गए थे इस चक्कर में मैं य पर नहीं करा रहा
हूं ठीक है अभी मेरे सामने एक नया नेम आया
है तो मैं इस नए नेम के नाम से एक और डटा
डाल देता हूं य पर मतलब जो मैं बताना चाह
रहा हूं ना वो चीज थोड़ी सी अपने को इजी
हो जाएगी ठीक
है ये सक्स
हिल कितनी बार आ भाई तीन बार दिख रहा है
मे को तो ठीक है तो यहां पर
मैं देता हूं ए एक और स्टेट य पर लिख देता
हूं
दिल्ली आपको नहीं भाई कोई दिक्कत की बात
आपको नहीं आती है तो अपन फिर भी ऐसा काम
करेंगे
कि आपको समझ में आएगा डोंट वरी मैं बस एक
अंदाजे के लिए पूछा किन किन को आती है
को नहीं आती जरूरी नहीं है कि आपको
प्रोग्रामिंग आए एसल पढ़ने के लिए अगर आप
पील एसल जाते हैं तो उसके लिए शद आपको नीड
पड़ सकती है ठीक है तो मैंने आप पर इसको
पेस्ट कर दिया है एक रो क्रिएट भी हो गया
है तो मैं देखूगा हा तो देखो अगर मैं
चाहूं अगर मैं चाहता हूं कि यार आउटपुट आए
अपना इस हिसाब से कि सबसे
पहले कि जिनका
सैलरी
से ऊपर हो ठीक है ना एंड वह राजस्थान के
भी हो मेरे पास य दो कंडीशन है ठीक है ना
कि यार जिनका सैलरी 85000 से ऊपर भी हो
एंड ए वह लोग राजस्थान से भी
हो ठीक है तो उसका मैं आउटपुट कैसे लाऊंगा
वह मैं अभी आपके सामने करके दिखाता हूं
देखो
सेलेक्ट स्टार
फ्रॉम
एंप्लॉई
वेर
सबसे पहले मेरी कंडीशन है कि वो अपने होने
चाहिए राजस्थान से र स्टेट इक्वल
टू
राजस्थान
एंड
सैलरी ग्रेटर देन
85000 तो देखो अभी क्या है ना देखो इसके
क्या तीन जनों की अपनी री मैं य से करके
दिखाता इसको देख अपने तीन जन की सैलरी
थी अपना 8 सेपर ठीक
है तीन जनों की सैलरी थी लेकिन य पर आट
में दो ही आए क्यों क्योंकि अपनी एक और
कंडीशन ने दे रखी उनका स्टेट राजस्थान भी
होना चाहिए ठीक है तो य राजस्थान एंड
ऑपरेटर क्या करता है ना एंड ऑपरेटर आपको
आउटपुट तभी यहां पर लाकर देगा जब आपकी
दोनों कंडीशन ट्रू होगी ठीक है ना मतलब
अगर यह वाली कंडीशन भी ट्रू एंड यह वाली
भी ट्रू तो ही य पर आउटपुट लाकर आपको
देगा अगर इसमें से एक भी कंडीशन फॉल्स
होती है तो यह आपको आउटपुट लाकर नहीं
देगा ठीक
है तोय आपको आउटपुट लाकर नहीं
देगा अगर दोनों फॉल्स हो तो ऑफकोर्स बात
है नहीं लाक देगा ठीक
है एंप्लॉई आईडी से भी मिल सकता है अगर आप
चाहते हो कि एप्ल आईडी जिनका 104 से ऊपर
हो उनका सैलरी भी अपना उससे ऊपर हो तो भी
दिख सकता है ठीक है ना य सर टेबल के बीच
में से डिटेल्स कैसे ऐड करे करते है ओ वट
के नंबर नहीं है वो डालना हो तो अपडेट
सेही होगा भाई अपडेट से ही आप मतलब डाटा
के बीच में कोई भी चेंस करने है तो यह चीज
अपने अपडेट से ही होगी ठीक है ना आपको
करना है अपडेट एंप्लॉई सेट फोन नंबर
इक्वल्स टू फोन नंबर यहां पर डाल देने का
है वेयर य एंप्लॉई आईडी डाल दो
106 तोसे आपका काम हो
जाएगा यार अगर आपको इतनी सी चीजें आएंगी
ना कि आपना अपडेट डिलीट इतनी क्वेरीज आपको
आईग तो डेटाबेस एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर बन जाओ तो
वो चीजें थोड़ी सी पॉसिबल नहीं होती हो
पाती है पूरा एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर तो नहीं बन
सकते आप मतलब हां डाटा डीवी के अंडर आप
काम कर सकते हो ताकि आपको और सीखने को
मिले क्योंकि यार एक डीबीए जो रहता है एक
बहुत बड़ी पोस्ट हो जाती है एक कंपनी के
अंदर क्योंकि यार कंपनी के लिए सबसे मेन
चीज रहती है डेटा ही ठीक है तोन डाटा के
साथ ही अगर आप डीबीआई अगर आपका अच्छा नहीं
होगा तो डेटा क्या उसने कैसे भी ऊपर नीचे
कर दिया या डेटा क्या को खेलना नहीं आता
रहेगा तो वहां पर थोड़ा बहुत क्रिटिकल से
सीन हो जाता है आप हो होप फुली समझ पा रहे
होंगे तो इसके लिए अपन को मतलब जो डीबीए
कंपनी लेती है वो अच्छा खासा ही लेती है
जिनको सब कुछ आता हो ठीक है
ना हां तो देखो अपना तो एंड ऑपरेटर का काम
क्या होता है ना अगर दोनों कंडीशन ट्रू
होगी तो ही वो आउटपुट लाके देगा ठीक है ना
अब मैं इसकी जगह प ना एक और भी ज्यादा
होते है और ज्यादा ठीक है
ना अगर मान लो
कि यहां पे स्ट राजस्थान भी हो तो भी
चलेगा एंड सैलरी 8 से ऊपर हो तो भी चलेगा
तो मैं अगर य एंटर करू तो यहां पर अभी चार
रिकॉर्ड अपने सामने लिखकर आके दे रहे हैं
ये चार रिकॉर्ड क्यों आए क्योंकि देखो
पहली कंडीशन अपनी ट्रू है यहां पर न के
राजस्थान है व सबका इसने दिखा दिया ठीक
है एंड सैलरी जिस जिसका 85 से ऊपर है उसने
सबका भी दिखा दिया ठीक है इसको फर्क नहीं
पड़ता कि दोनों कंडीशन ट्रू हो कोई सी भी
एक ट्रू होगी तो भी आउटपुट लाकर देगा ठीक
है ना इस वाले के अंदर देखो एक ट्रू हो
रही है एक फॉल्स है तो भी इसने आउटपुट
लाके दिया इसके अंदर क्या हो रहा था ना कि
ये वाली और ये वाली दोनों ट्रू हो रही थी
तो ही इसने आउटपुट लाकर दिया फिर इसने चेक
किया फिर से ये वाली एंड ये वाली ट्रू हो
रही है तोही इसने लाकर दिया बट और क्या
करता है ना कि दोनों में से कोई एक भी रो
के अंदर अगर ये वैल्यू ट्रू होती है तो भी
लाके
देगा ठीक है तो अगर मान लो स्टेट राजस्थान
होगा तो भी लाके देखा च से ऊपर होगी तो भी
ये लाकर देगा तो इसलिए इसने ऐसे लाक दिया
होप फुली आपको और और एंड के बीच में
डिफरेंसेस पता लग गए होंगे और के अंदर
क्या रहता है कि दोनों में से कोई एक भी
कंडीशन ट्रू होगी तो आपको आपको आउटपुट
लाके देगा ठीक है बट एंड के अंदर आपको
दोनों का दोनों जो कंडीशंस है वो ट्रू
होनी मांगती है तो ही जाकर वो आउटपुट लाकर
देगा ठीक है आपको आप लोगों को समझ में आ
रहा है ना एंड और र के अंदर आपको डिफरेंस
समझ में आया आपका ऐसा ही आईडी और पासवर्ड
जाके चेक होता है किसी भी डेटाबेस के अंदर
आपका ऐसे टेबल बनी हुई रती हैके अर आपका
आईडी और पासवर्ड डाला हुआ रहता है तो व
एंड ऑपरेटर से ही जाकर चेक करते
हैं ठीक है कि आपका क्या
है ठीक
है एंड ऑप से आपका आईडी और पासवर्ड चेक
किया जाता है एंड अगर आपने अगर मैनुअल अगर
स्ल इंजेक्शन वगैरह अगर आपने देखे हो होते
हुए तो उसके अंदर वो इस एंड की जगह पे ऑड
लगाने का कोशिश करते हैं इंजेक्शन के वक्त
में ठीक है ताकि ताकि अगर आपका अगर मान लो
अगर अगर आपको कोई स्पेसिफाइड यूजर को ही
लॉगइन करना है तो वो उनका यूजर नेम पता कर
लेते हैं यूजर नेम पता करना कोई बड़ी बात
नहीं होती किसी भी वेबसाइट के अंदर किसी
भी जने का ठीक है तो यूजर नेम पता करने के
बाद वो एंड को ऑन में कन्वर्ट करने की
कोशिश करते हैं अगर वो एंड को ऑन में
कन्वर्ट करने में सक्सेसफुल हो जाते हैं
तो वह पासवर्ड कुछ भी डाले वहां पर उस फिर
भी वह जाकर अपना वैल्यू एग्जीक्यूट हो
जाती
है यह चीजें रहती है अग अगर आप एसए
इंजेक्शन को डीप पढ़ो तो ऐसा जाकर ऐसे भी
अटैक्स परफॉर्म होते हैं एसक्यूएल
इंजेक्शन के
अंदर ठीक है तो इसलिए मैं आपको यह चीजें
पढ़ा रहा हूं ताकि आपको इन चीजों का समझ
में आए आप खुद के जब आप करने
जाओ तो आप लोग खुद भी समझ
सको कि कैसे आपको एक बड़ा एसक्यूएल
इंजेक्शन लगा देने का है किसी वेबसाइट के
अंदर मतलब ये इलीगली नहीं मतलब पूछ के यार
मतलब लीगल तरीके
से तो ये कैसे काम करते ची अप बाद में
जाके देखेंगे अगर थोड़ा अच्छा खा और
रिस्पांस रहा एंड अगर और भी अपने पास टाइम
रहा तो अपन जरूर एक मब खुद का बनाकर जैसा
मुझे किसी ने पूछा था ऊपर जरूर देख सकते
हैं बाद में
यूजर नेम तो क्या भाई किसी भी ग्राम के
अंदर यूजरनेम देखोगे तो क्या आप उसके यूजर
आईडी मतलब प्रोफाइल में जाओ यूजरनेम दिख
जाएगा नेम क्या होता है भाई यने बिग डील
किसी भी न जा किसी वेइट केर किसी रने
निकालना क्या भाई यार छोटी बात कर दी आपने
गुरा भाई चलो ठीक है आप शायद समझ पा रहे
समझ पा रहे होंगे कि मेरा क्या कहने का
मतलब
है ठीक है हां तो अभी अपन देखते हैं डिलीट
को ठीक है अगर मान लो आपको रिकॉर्ड अगर
डिलीट करने रहे तो उस केस में आपको क्या
करने का है आपका मान लो को स्पेसिफाइड
रिकॉर्ड डिलीट करने का जैसे मान लो क्या
ये ओपी बड भाई ने अपना नंबर नहीं डाला है
मुझे इनका डाटा रिकॉर्ड डिलीट कर देने का
है अपने डेटाबेस में से मतलब उड़ा देने का
है तो उस केस में य प क्या
लिखूंगा डिलीट
फ्रॉम एंप्लॉई
वेर ईम पी आईडी इक्व ट 10 या देखो मैंने
एमपी आईडी ही क्यों य पर ले रहा हूं इसका
क्या कारण है क्योंकि देखो यहां प एमपी
आईडी हमने प्राइमरी की है अबना प्राइमरी
की ना ये यूनिक रहेगी एंड खाली नहीं होगी
ना खाली भी नहीं होगी तो अगर मैं को
स्पेसिफाइड र्ड ही डिलीट करना चाह ता हूं
तो उस केस में मैं हमेशा एंप्लॉई आईडी का
ही इस्तेमाल करूंगा अब अगर मान लो कि अगर
मैं यहां पर नेम का इस्तेमाल करता हूं ओपी
बोट अब ना ये ओपी बोट एक सिंगल नेम तो
नहीं होगा ना आपका डेटाबेस के अंदर ओपी
बोट नाम के बहुत से नेम हो सकते आप
डेटाबेस के अंदर तो अगर मैं यहां पर वेर
नेम इ इक्वल टू ओपी बोट लिख दूंगा तो
जितने भी लोगों का नेम ओपी बोट होगा उ
सबका रिकॉर्ड डिलीट हो
जाएगा ठीक है तो उस चीज से बचने के लिए
अपन प्राइमरी कीज को इस्तेमाल करते
हैं ठीक है तो इस इसलिए अपन यहां पे
एंप्लॉई आईडी का इस्तेमाल करते हैं तो मैं
यहां पर अगर ऐसे एंटर करूं तो वन रिकॉर्ड
डिलीटेड तो सक्सेसफुली अपन ने एक रिकॉर्ड
डिलीट कर दिया
है ठीक है तो ओ वड भाई का रिकॉर्ड य से
चला गया ओ वड भाई मेरे को आपसे कोई पर्सनल
गजस नहीं है मैंने बस ऐसे ही डेमोंस्ट्रेट
के लिए किया है डिस्क्लेमर
रुद्रा भाई आपका डिलीट नहीं किया
है डोंट वरी हा तो अगर मान लो कि यार अगर
आप अच्छी डीबीए नहीं हो आपसे गलती से अगर
य यर की कंडीशन नहीं
लगी ठीक है उस केस में क्या होगा ना छ का
छ रो डिलीट हो
जाएगा पूरा डेटाबेस खाली
ठीक है आप समझ पा रहे होगे कि मैं क्या
कहना चाह रहा हूं कि कितना अपन को
बहुत कंपलसरी हो जाता है एक अच्छा डीब का
होना एक छोटी सी गलती एंड सारा काम
खत्म ठीक है तो देखो बट डिलीट का है ना एक
चीज अच्छा है कि अगर आपने डिलीट कर दिया
तो आप इसको ना माप से रिट्रीव कर सकते हो
रोल बैक करके जब आप प्रोडक्शन में काम कर
रहे होगे उस वक्त रोल बैक कर सकोगे अभी
मैं इसके अंदर अपना लोकल कर रहा हूं तो
रोल बैक शायद मैं नहीं कर सकता
हूं ठीक है और जो जो मैंने आपको शायद कल
ट्रंकेट्स अपन को है डिलीट से अपन कंडीशन
लगा के डाटा उड़ा सकते हैं ठीक है बट
ट्रंकेट्स
एग्जांपल की तौर से ठीक है कंपनी नेस हुई
है नेस मतलब समझते हो ना आप लोग
हा हा तो इसलिए डेटा मतलब डीवी थोड़ा
अच्छा होना जरूरी है
हा तो डाटा डिलीट डिलीट करने से लेकर
थोड़ा अच्छे खासी चीज तक अपन जा चुके हैं
हा सो गाइस हां तो आज के लिए इतना ही आप
जो टास्क है व टास्क आपका
रहेगा टास्क
बताता देखो सबसे प तो स्क्रीन खोता
हा क्या हो जाता एक तो हा एक तोर नल
वैल्यू है तो आप पहले उसके अर डटा मुझे
डाल के दिखाओ ठीक है ना और साथ मैंने और
क्या क्या दिया था के र प हा एक और था
टास्क आपका
कि आपको यह आउटपुट के वक्त में जो यह अपना
ऊपर जो कॉलम का नेम आता है इस कॉलम के नेम
को चेंज करके दिखाना है एक अलाइज नेम से व
अलाइज नेम कैसे लगाते है मैंने आपको
दिखाया था तो आपको एक बार ट्राई करके
देखना है हिंट में देता हूं कॉलम का नेम
डालना एस अलाइज नेम कॉमा कॉलम का नेम एस
अलाइज नेम इतना ही मैं हिंट दे सकता हूं
उसके अलावा आपको ही करके मुझे इसका
स्क्रीनशॉट खींच के भेजने का है एंड आपको
ऐसे टेबल बना के टेबल बना के भी देखनी है
ठीक है आपका तीन टास्क है एक टेबल बना के
देखने का एक को अगर आपने नल वैल्यू डाल
रखी है तो उस नल वैल्यू में आप डेटा अपडेट
करके आपको डेटा वहां पर डाल देने का है
ठीक है तीसरा टास्क है आपको कि कॉलम का
नेम अला मतलब कॉलम का एक अलाइज नेम डालने
का है आपको ये तीन टास्क है आपको ठीक है
इसके स्क्रीनशॉट खीच के कुछ नहीं करना
आपको लिंकन के अंदर जाना
है लिंकन में जाने के बाद में यहां पर
डेनिक्स मैं जाने का है आपको डेफ साइबर
सिक्योरिटी हमारे कंपनी के पेज के अंदर
जाने का है पोस्ट के अंदर जाने का है
पोस्ट में जाने के बाद जैसे डे थ का आया
है देखो कोई कमेंट नहीं करता है ठीक है ना
इस चक्कर के अंदर मैं बिल्कुल भी रिस नहीं
लेता हूं किसी को भी देने का नोट्स टस है
नाय देखो पहले भी अभी भी किसी के भी टास्क
किसी के भी कमेंट्स नहीं आया है देखो पहले
मेरे पाइथन वाले के अंदर भी नहीं आया था
किसी के भी टास्क होगा इसके अंदर हा सेवन
कमेंट्स है यहां पर ठीक है बट यहां पर कोई
भी टास्क का कमेंट नहीं है आज टास्क वाले
भी कमेंट है बट एक दो जनों ने किया
है तो फसे भी
अ इस पोस्ट के अंदर किसी ने टास्क नहीं
डाला इस चक्कर में आप लोग जो नोट्स की
मांग करते हो तो मुझे वो देने में सेव
थोड़ा अच्छा नहीं लगता है क्योंकि आप लोग
अपना टास्क नहीं करते हो इसलिए तो यार
टास्क करो यार ताकि मेरे को भी अच्छा लगे
आप आप लोग को नोटस देने का देखो मेरे पास
सेव पड़े रहते हैं मुझे कोई इशू नहीं होगा
एक ड्रैग एंड ड्रॉप करने का
आपको टे ग्रा चैनल पर ही मिलेगा एंड टे
ग्रा चैनल का लिंक आपको इस वीडियो के
डिस्क्रिप्शन में या फिर हर वीडियो के
डिस्क्रिप्शन में आपको टे ग्रा चैनल का
लिंक या कंपनी के अड पेज मतलब कहीं पर भी
आपको ा चैनल का लिंक मिल ही
जाएगा ठीक है तो आपको यहां पर कमेंट में
डालने का है वो जो मैंने न तीन टास्क आपको
बताया फिर से रिपीट करता हूं आपको एक टेबल
बना के दिखाने की है ऐसी ही दूसरा आपको
कॉलम के अलाइज नेम डालने के हैं एंड तीसरा
अगर आपने कोई नल वैल्यू डाल रखी है तो
उसमें
आपको वैल्यू ऐड करने का अपडेट करने का है
एंड आपने वैल्यू कैसे डाली आपको वो भी य
पर डेमोंस्ट्रेट करने का है स्क्रीनशॉट्स
के अंदर ठीक है तो आज के लिए टा इतना ही
और आज के लिए आपकी क्लास भी इतनी सी सो
मैं क्क फीडबैक ले लेते हैं आप लोग को आज
की क्लास कैसी लगी क्योंकि बहुत कम लोग
में देखते जा रहा कि ब जने बहुत कम होते
रहे हो रहे हैं स फिर भी एक बार मैं देख
लेता हूं कि आपको आज की क्लास कैसी
लगी कुछ इंप्रूवमेंट या कुछ भी चीज अगर
आपको लगे कि हां भाई हार्दिक भाई ये चीज
करो तो जरूर आपके फीडबैक्स को नजरअंदाज
बिल्कुल नहीं किया
जाएगा
चलो बढ़िया एक जन काया कोई बात नहीं चलो
आज के लिए इतना ही थैंक यू टाटा बाय बाय
गुड नाइट शबा खर जय हिंद वंदे मातर कांग
सबको अपने सक्सेसफुल लैंडिंग के
लिए चंदन के सो टाटा बाय बाय सी यू सून
सबको नेक्स्ट वाले डे फव के अंदर अभी सबसे
मिलेंगे सो बाय बाय
टाटा